este laboratorio en la ciudad francesa
de lyon está buscando la fórmula que
podría ayudar a acabar con la pandemia
de kobe 19 aquí estamos trabajando en la
vacuna universal contra las distintas
variantes de coronal y si creen que han
encontrado la correcta ahora sólo están
buscando la dosis adecuada la compañía
biotecnológica ha estado trabajando en
una vacuna universal contra la gripe
desde 2013 y ahora están poniendo en
práctica todo lo que han aprendido en la
lucha contra el coronavirus la mayoría
de los proyectos se centran en la cadena
de proteínas del coronavirus pero a
medida que esas cadenas cambian tú
tienes que cambiar la vacuna lo que
estamos haciendo tiene como objetivo lo
que está en el interior del virus lo que
significa que aunque el exterior también
la vacuna necesaria no lo hace si todo
va bien los ensayos clínicos podrían
empezar a finales de 2021 a medida que
aparecen nuevas variantes los
científicos de todo el mundo están a la
caza de la fórmula capaz de combatir
todas las mutaciones pero la vacuna
universal es siquiera una posibilidad
los investigadores no están seguros
creo que el término vacuna universal es
una estrategia de marketing lo que
probablemente llegará al mercado no será
una vacuna universal sino una vacuna que
te protege contra distintas variantes lo
que ya es mejor que las dosis que hay en
el mercado ahora pero no algo que yo
llamaría vacuna universal
de buck sanders el a medida que avanzan
las investigaciones de nuevas vacunas
los científicos están de acuerdo en una
cosa la gente debe confiar y aplicarse
de las que ya están disponibles